THE "CNN NEWSROOM."
TONIGHT, CNN HAS OBTAINED NEW
FOOTAGE OF THE JANUARY 6th U.S.
CAPITOL INSURRECTION NOT SEEN ON
TELEVISION UNTIL TODAY.
IT'S FROM A BRITISH DOCUMENTARY
FILMMAKER AND IT FEATURES NEW
IMAGES OF THE VIOLENT CHAOS THAT
DESCENDED ON THE CAPITOL THAT
DAY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> RIGHT NOW, THE PEOPLE IN THE
CAPITOL ARE SHELTERING IN PLACE.
THEY HAVE GONE TO THEIR SAFE
ROOMS OR WHATEVER AND THEY'RE
SHELTERING IN PLACE.
WE HAVE THE CAPITOL.
>> THAT ANGRY CROWD SWARMING
ONTO THE GROUND, SMASHING
WINDOWS, FIGHTING THE OFFICERS
TRYING TO STOP THEM AND SHOUTING
WE HAVE THE CAPITOL.
THIS DISTURBING FOOTAGE CAPS A
WEEK THAT SAW THE LAST PUBLIC
HEARING OF THE J-6 COMMITTEE
BEFORE THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS.
IT ENDED WITH A DRAMATIC
FLOURISH.
A UNANIMOUS VOTE TO SUBPOENA
FORMER PRESIDENT DONALD J.
TRUMP.
THE QUESTION IS WILL HE OR WON'T
HE COMPLY.
EARLIER TODAY, COMMITTEE MEMBER
ADAM KINZINGER SHARED HIS
THOUGHTS.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE THAT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, IF THE
PRESIDENT REFUSES, SHOULD HOLD
HIM IN CRIMINAL CONTEMPT?
>> LOOK, THAT'S A BRIDGE WE
CROSS IF WE HAVE TO GET THERE.
YOU KNOW, LOOK, WE WELL
RECOGNIZE THE FACT THAT BECAUSE
OF THE COMMITTEE ONLY BEING ABLE
TO EXIST UNTIL THE END OF THIS
CONGRESSIONAL YEAR BECAUSE THAT
WAS THE MANDATE, WE'RE AT A BIT
OF A TIME LIMIT HERE.
AS WE'RE WRAPPING UP THE
INVESTIGATION, WE'RE ALSO
PURSUING NEW LEADS AND FACTS AND
WE WANT TO SPEAK TO THE
PRESIDENT.
>> CONGRESSWOMAN AND J-6
COMMITTEE MEMBER ZOE LOFGREN
JOINS US NOW WITH MORE.
AS WE HEARD THERE, THE CLOCK IS
TICKING LOUDLY.
WILL THE COMMITTEE BE ABLE TO
WRAP UP ITS WORK BY THE END OF
THE YEAR?
>> OF COURSE.
WE'VE ALL KNOWN, ALL SELECT
COMMITTEES, INCLUDING THIS ONE,
ARE CREATED FOR THE LIFE OF THAT
CONGRESS AND THIS CONGRESS ENDS
AT THE END OF DECEMBER.
WE'VE ALWAYS KNOWN THAT.
AND WE WILL COMPLETE OUR WORK BY
THAT TIME.
>> WE SAW NEW VIDEO ON THURSDAY.
THERE'S A NEW VIDEO RELEASED
TODAY INCLUDING ONE MAN WHO SAID
LAWMAKERS SHOULD BE EXTERMINATED
LIKE COCKROACHES.
HAVE WE SEEN THE WORST OR IS
THERE MORE EVIDENCE YOUR
COMMITTEE HAS NOT YET MADE
PUBLIC?
>> WELL, WE JUST HAVE VOLUMES OF
VIDEO OF THE RIOTERS AND
HORRIBLE THINGS THAT THEY WERE
DOING, YOU KNOW, IN THE CONTEXT
OF -- ABOUT TWO-HOUR HEARING,
YOU CAN'T PLAY IT ALL.
CERTAINLY THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT
THIS VIOLENT ARMED MOB INTENDED
TO KILL PEOPLE, TO HANG MIKE
PENCE, TO TRY AND KILL NANCY
PELOSI AND THE REST OF US AND TO
STOP THE COUNT OF THE ELECTORAL
COUNT AND STOP THE PEACEFUL
TRANSFER OF POWER.
THAT'S WHAT THEY TRIED TO DO.
>> THE LAST HEARING, THERE WAS A
LOT OF FOCUS ABOUT THE SECRET
SERVICE.
I KNOW THE COMMITTEE HAS BEEN
SIFTING THROUGH A LOT OF
DOCUMENTS HANDED OVER BY THE
SECRET SERVICE.
EXCUSE ME.
FORMER SECRET SERVICE MEMBER WHO
WORKED IN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, HIS LAWYER TOLD
CNN THAT HE IS NOT BEEN ENTERED
BY THE COMMITTEE SINCE MARCH AND
THERE HAVE BEEN A LOT OF
REVELATIONS THAT HAVE HAPPENED
SINCE THEN, INCLUDING FROM
CASSIDY HUTCHINSON.
WHY HAS HE NOT BEEN BROUGHT BACK
TO TESTIFY AND TESTIFY UNDER
OATH?
>> HE WILL BE.
YOU KNOW, WE HAD A LOT OF
QUESTIONS, BUT WE WANTED TO GET
THROUGH ALL THE DOCUMENTARY
EVIDENCE THAT WE HAVE NOW BEEN
PROVIDED, OVER A MILLION
DOCUMENTS.
SO IT'S -- IT TOOK A LOT OF TIME
TO GO THROUGH THAT.
WE HAVE SUCCESSFULLY GONE
THROUGH IT.
AND NOW WE'RE IN A POSITION IN
THE VERY NEAR FUTURE TO CALL THE
WITNESSES FROM THE SECRET
SERVICE BACK IN FOR A FEW
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS.
>> WHO SPECIFICALLY -- SO YOU
SAID TONY ORNATO.
WHO ELSE?
>> WELL, THERE WAS ALSO
MR. ANGLE AND THERE MAY BE A FEW
OTHERS.
I DON'T WANT TO MENTION ALL OF
THEIR NAMES ON TELEVISION.
BUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE GETTING THE STRAIGHT
STORIES.
SOME OF THE TESTIMONY RECEIVED
DOESN'T SEEM TO ALIGN WITH SOME
OF THE DOCUMENTS.
SO WE HAVE A NEED TO UNDERSTAND
THAT BETTER FROM THEM.
>> IN WHAT WAY?
>> WELL, I'M NOT GOING TO GO
THROUGH THE INTERVIEW ON TV,
BUT, FOR EXAMPLE --
>> GO AHEAD --
>> THERE WAS A REPRESENTATION
MADE PUBLICLY AS WELL AS IN THE
INTERVIEWS THAT THERE WAS NO
MONITORING OF SOCIAL MEDIA.
THAT WE KNOW NOW WAS NOT
CORRECT.
YOU KNOW, CERTAINLY DOWNPLAYING
THE KNOWLEDGE OF VIOLENCE, THAT
WAS -- THEY KNEW WELL IN ADVANCE
AND CERTAINLY BY THE 5th OF
JANUARY WHAT THEY WERE FACING.
NEVERTHELESS, THEY SENT THE VICE
PRESIDENT UP TO THE CAPITOL HILL
WITH A FAIRLY SMALL GROUP OF
PEOPLE TO PROTECT THEM INTO WHAT
WAS -- SHOULD HAVE OBVIOUSLY
BEEN FORESEEN AS A POTENTIALLY
VERY DANGEROUS SITUATION.
>> WHAT ABOUT THE SITUATION THAT
CASSIDY HUTCHINSON HAS TESTIFIED
TO ABOUT TRUMP LUNGING AT THE
SECRET SERVICE OFFICER IN THE
VEHICLE.
WE KNOW THAT THERE WAS TESTIMONY
REGARDING -- AT THE HEARING
REGARDING POTENTIAL OBSTRUCTION
ON THAT ALLEGATION SPECIFICALLY.
WHAT MORE CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT
THAT?
IS THAT ONE OF THE REASONS YOU
ALSO WANT TO BRING BACK THESE
OTHER SECRET SERVICE MEMBERS,
FORMER, I SHOULD SAY.
>> THE TESTIMONY WAS THAT
MR. ORNATO TOLD HER THAT HE HAD
LUNGED AT IT.
BUT I THINK THE REAL POINT IS
THAT THE PRESIDENT INTENDED --
THEN-PRESIDENT INTENDED TO GO TO
THE CAPITOL WITH THE ARMED MOB
AND WE HAVE CORROBORATING
EVIDENCE ON THAT POINT.
CERTAINLY THE --
>> ABSOLUTELY.
BUT THAT WASN'T -- JUST TO
CLARIFY, THAT MIGHT HAVE BEEN MY
BAD NOT BEING CLEAR ENOUGH IN MY
QUESTION, IT'S NOT ABOUT THAT,
IT'S ABOUT THE FACT THAT PETE
AGUILAR SAID THERE WAS AN
OBSTRUCTION ALLEGATION INVOLVING
THAT ALLEGATION IN PARTICULAR.
CAN YOU EXPAND ON THAT A LITTLE
BIT?
>> I REALLY CAN'T AT THIS POINT.
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT THE
INCIDENT, BUT THE TESTIMONY AND
I WILL SAY, WE HAVE BROADLY
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE ADVICE GIVEN
TO SOME WITNESSES AND WHETHER
ALL THE WITNESSES WERE
COMPLETELY CANDID WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE'RE INTERESTED IN AND I
THINK THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
WILL BE VERY INTERESTED IN.
>> SO IT SOUNDS LIKE WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING IS YOU HAVE EVIDENCE OF
WITNESS TAMPERING?
>> I CAN'T GO INTO IT MORE THAN
THAT.
>> LAST QUESTION.
IF THE FORMER PRESIDENT DOES NOT
RESPOND TO THIS SUBPOENA, DO YOU
THINK THE COMMITTEE SHOULD SEND
A REFERRAL FOR CRIMINAL CONTEMPT
TO THE DOJ?
>> WE HAVEN'T DECIDED THAT.
WE EXPECT HIM TO COME IN BECAUSE
HE HAS A LEGAL OBLIGATION TO
COME IN.
OF COURSE, HE ALSO HAD A LEGAL
OBLIGATION TO SEE THAT THE LAWS
WERE FAITHFULLY EXECUTED, WHICH
HE COMPLETELY IGNORED ON JANUARY
6th.
SO WE'LL SEE.
WE WOULD LIKE HIM TO COME IN.
WHETHER OR NOT DOJ WOULD
PROSECUTE, THAT'S REALLY
SOMETHING THEY NEED TO THINK
ABOUT.
I CAN'T MAKE THAT DECISION FOR
TH